so recently he decided to release a
photo of his wife Lena with five men
behind him let's pull it up
oh oh my gosh one guy wasn't enough now
we're going to do not one not two not
three not four but five men I think this
is very sad I think it's very sad I
think it's sad because one day again uh
Pearl cares about the kids here if you
guys wanted to just be in a relationship
and do this craziness that's fine that's
on you but I think that children have
right and I think it is your
responsibility as a parent to not do
things that would make it difficult for
your kid to grow up and I don't know why
they keep engaging in behavior that one
day their kid is going to have to grow
up and see I think it's wrong and I
think it's selfish so